ich hatte vor zwei tagen die möglichkeit
nach ahrweiler zu fahren in der sozialen
ground zero dieser flut katastrophe vor
acht neun wochen und ich muss sagen
alles was ich dort erlebt habe alles was
ich dort gesehen habe alles was ich dort
gehört habe von dem betroffenen von den
opfern von den helfern waren alles
geschichten die ich mir niemals hätte
vorstellen können der staat ist dort in
dieser in diesem katastrophengebiet
nicht mehr präsent der stadt hat dort
trotz aller versprechen und deswegen
wollte ich mir selber und deswegen
wollte bild sich selber ein bild von der
lage machen hat die menschen dort
entgegen aller versprechungen im stich
gelassen wir haben menschen dinge
erzählt die mich fassungslos zurück
gehalten gelassen haben von dem schock
den sie jetzt selber weg räumen müssen
weil der staat sich nicht mal darum
kümmert den schutz den menschen aus
ihren zerstörten häusern aus ihren
zerstörten existenzen raus räumen
beseitigen zu lassen von schikanen durch
das ordnungsamt ich hab die menschen
dort gefragt habt ihr denn jetzt geld
bekommen
gelächter in dem raum in dem ich dort
war niemand dort hat abgesehen von den
kleinen 1500 euro soforthilfen am anfang
geld bekommen das was ich dort gesehen
habe ist dass der staat die
bundeskanzlerin das muss man sagen
vorneweg die dort mehrfach warum auch
wahlkampf zu machen all die versprechen
die sie dort abgegeben haben nicht
eingehalten haben und die die art und
weise wie menschen in diesem land in
diesem viertreichste industrieland der
welt im stich gelassen werden können vom
staat er war etwas das mich tatsächlich
zutiefst erschüttern das einzelfälle
julian
50 leute waren glaube ich eingeladen zu
diesem stammtisch oder repräsentiert das
wirklich die situation für alle genau
diese frage habe ich natürlich auch
gestellt thomas und man hat mir dort vor
ort versichert und ich bin durch diesen
ort gegangen und hab es mir mit eigenen
augen angeguckt dass das die
repräsentativ ist dass das genau das ist
was dort allen menschen wieder fällt in
diesem alter sagen die menschen ist der
staat nicht mehr da ein punkt der mich
ganz besonders bewegt hat die bundeswehr
ist abgerückt da frage ich mich warum
muss die bundeswehr dort überhaupt
abrücken es gibt so viel zu tun da
liegen immer noch zertrümmerte autos
herum da sind immer noch brücken nicht
fertiggestellt da holen menschen immer
noch den schlamm aus ihren häusern die
bundeswehr war ja ursprünglich da wer um
gottes willen entscheidet die bundeswehr
dort abzuziehen anstatt dort noch mehr
tausende und vielleicht zehntausende
soldaten zu schicken die dieses jahr 50
kilometer lange teil das da betroffen
ist aus dieser katastrophe herausholt
ist mir persönlich und egal was man sich
auch fragen sind ja 30 milliarden an
hilfe beschlossen worden 30 milliarden
enorme summe die kanzlerin hat selber
gesagt das muss jetzt auch abgerufen
werden liegt das problem also bei den
örtlichen behörden landrat es ist ein
totales behörden chaos da ich habe man
stellt sich das immer so vor wenn
wirklich was schlimmes passiert dann
kommt jemand das wird ja auch mal
versprochen und hilft unbürokratisch und
von unbürokratisch stellt man sich doch
vor da ist ein stand an dem stand stehen
menschen aus der verwaltung und wenn ich
ein problem habe wenn meine existenz
vernichtet ist dann gehe ich da hin und
lasse mir helfen und mir wird geholfen
und ich habe gefragt gibt es diesen
stand gibt es diese möglichkeit die
verwaltung vor ort anzusprechen wieder
gelächter in der gruppe mit der ich
gesprochen habe nein man beantwortet
unsere anrufe nicht man beantwortet
unsere mails nicht wir haben tatsächlich
von niemandem der hier politische
verantwortung trägt oder verantwortung
in der verwaltung noch irgendwas gehört
also das was du gefragt hast kann man
einfach mit nein beantworten menschen
haben dort keine möglichkeit wenn die
kanzlerin gesagt das muss jetzt
abgerufen werden bin ich gespannt wie
das funktionieren wird denn die
möglichkeit der dinge schnell und
unbürokratisch abzurufen die scheint
nach allem was mir dort geschildert
worden ist in keiner weise zu bestehen
was mir auch aus meinem freundeskreis
zugetragen wird ist dass viele natürlich
gespendet haben alle die ich kenne haben
gespendet auch diese menschen sind
natürlich enttäuscht wenn wir solche
bilder dann sehen dass sich da nichts
tut warum kommt das geld von uns denn
dort auch nicht an auch das wurde dort
angesprochen vor ort das recherchieren
wir hier noch bei bild deutschland hilft
eine aktion für die so viele gespendet
haben da sagte man mir vor ort man wisse
nicht wo dieses geld aufgetaucht sei wo
dieses geld jetzt sei immer partei sei
es nicht angeblich werden damit größere
organisationen
größere organisation versorgt aber auch
da haarsträubende geschichten man
erzählte mir von einer suppenküche die
man gemeinsam dort errichtet hat bis man
dann bis dann versucht wurde diese
suppenküche die aus der solidarität der
menschen dort die enorm und gewaltig und
bewegend ist bis man versucht hat diese
suppenküche dann zu vertreiben damit das
deutsche rote kreuz dort übernehmen kann
die für diese mahlzeiten sehr sehr viel
geld bekommen
[Musik]